when we use the word architect or
designer what we usually mean is a
professional someone who gets paid and
we tend to assume that it's those
professionals who are going to be the
ones to help us solve the really big
systemic design challenges that we face
like climate change
urbanization social inequality that's
how kind of working presumption and I
think it's wrong actually
in 2008 I was just about to graduate
from architecture school after several
years and go out and get a job and this
happened the economy ran out of jobs and
a couple of things struck me about this
one
don't listen to career advisors and to
actually this is a fascinating paradox
for architecture which is that as a
society we've never needed design
thinking more and yet architecture was
literally becoming unemployed it strikes
me that we talk very deeply about design
but actually there's an economics behind
architecture that we don't talk about
and I think we need to and a good place
to start is your own paycheck so as a
bottom of the wrong architecture
graduate I might expect to earn about
twenty four thousand pounds it's about
thirty six thirty seven thousand dollars
now in terms of the whole world's
population that already puts me in the
top 1.95 richest people which raises the
question of who is it I'm working for
the uncomfortable fact is that actually
almost everything that we call
architecture today is actually the
business of designing for about the
richest 1% of the world's population and
it always has been
the reason why we forgot that is because
the times that history when architecture
did the most transform society were
those times when actually the 1% were
billed on behalf of the 99% for various
different reasons whether that was
through philanthropy in the 19th century
communism in the early 20th the welfare
state and most recently of course
through this inflated real estate bubble
and all of those booms in their own
various ways have now
kick the bucket and we're back in this
situation where the smartest designers
and architects in the world are only
really able to work for 1% of the
population now it's not just that that's
bad for democracy though I think it
probably is it's actually not very
clever business strategy actually I
think the challenge facing the next
generation of architects is how are we
going to turn our client from the 1% to
100% and I want to offer three slightly
counterintuitive ideas for how it might
be done the first is I think we need to
question this idea that architecture is
about making buildings actually a
building is about the most expensive
solution you can think of to almost any
given problem and fundamentally design
should be much much more interested in
solving problems and creating new
conditions so here's a story the office
were working with a school and they had
an old Victorian school building and
they said to the architects look our
corridors are an absolute nightmare
they're far too small they get congested
between classes there's bullying we
can't control them so what we want you
to do is replant our entire building and
we know it's going to cost several
million pounds but we reconciled to the
fact and the team thought about this and
they went away and they said actually
don't do that instead get rid of the
school bell
instead of having one school bell that
goes off once have several smaller
school bells that go off in different
places in different times distribute the
traffic through the corridors it solves
the same problem but instead of spending
several million pounds you spend several
hundred pounds now it looks like you're
doing yourself out of a job but you're
not you actually make yourself more
useful Architects are actually really
really good at this kind of resourceful
strategic thinking and and the problem
is that like a lot of design professions
we got fixated on the idea of providing
a particular kind of consumer product
and I don't think that needs to be the
case anymore a second idea worth
questioning is this 20th century thing
that mass architecture is about big big
buildings and big finance actually we've
got ourselves locked into this
industrial era mindset which says that
the only people who can make cities are
large organisations or corporations who
build on
behalf procuring whole neighborhoods in
single monolithic projects and of course
form follows finance so what you end up
with our single monolithic neighborhoods
based on this kind of one size fits all
kind of model and a lot of people can't
even afford them but what if actually
it's possible now for cities to be made
not just by the few with a lot but also
by the many with a bit and when they do
they bring with them a completely
different set of values about the place
that they want to live and it raises
really interesting questions about how
will we plan cities how will we finance
development
how will we sell design services what
would it mean for democratic societies
to offer their citizens our right to
build and in a way it should be kind of
obvious right that in the 21st century
maybe cities could be developed by
citizens and thirdly we need to remember
that from a strictly economic point of
view design shares a category with sex
and care of elderly mostly it's done by
amateurs
and that's a good thing most of the work
takes place outside of the monetary
economy and what's called the social
economy or the core economy which is
people doing it for themselves and the
problem is that up until now it was the
monetary economy which had all the
infrastructure and all the tools so the
challenge we face is how are we going to
build the tools the infrastructure and
the institutions for architectures
social economy and that began with open
source software and over the last few
years it's been moving into the physical
world with open source hardware which
are freely shared blueprints that anyone
can download and make for themselves and
that's where 3d printing gets really
really interesting right when suddenly
you had a 3d printer that was
open-source the parts were which could
be made on another 3d printer or the
same idea here which is for a CNC
machine which is like a large printer
that can cut sheets of plywood what
these technologies are doing is
radically lowering the thresholds of
time and cost and skill they're
challenging the idea that if you want
something to be affordable it's got to
be one size fits all and they're
distributing massively really complex
many fat
incapabilities we're moving into this
future where the factory is everywhere
and increasingly that means that the
design team is everyone that really is
an industrial revolution when we think
that the major ideological conflicts
that we inherited but all based around
this question of who should control the
means of production and these
technologies are coming back with the
solution actually maybe no one all of us
and we were fascinated by what that
might mean for architecture so about a
year and a half and ago we started
working on a project called wiki house
and wiki house is an open source
construction system and the idea is to
make it possible for anyone to go online
access a free t-shirt library of 3d
models which they can download and adapt
in at the moment Sketchup because it's
free and it's easy to use and almost at
the click of a switch it can generate a
set of cutting files which allow them in
effect to print out the parts from a
house using a CNC machine and a standard
sheet material like plywood and the
parts are all numbered and basically
what you end up with is a really big
IKEA kit and it goes together without
any bolts it uses wedge and peg
connections and even the mallets to make
it can be provided on the cutting sheets
as well and a team of about 2 or 3
people working together can build this
they don't need any traditional
construction skills they don't need a
huge array of power tools or anything
like that and they can build a small
house of about this size in about a day
and what you end up with is just the
basic chassis of a house onto which you
can then apply systems like windows and
cladding and insulation and services
based on what's cheap and what's
available of course the house is never
finished we're shifting our heads here
so the house is not a finished product
with the CNC machine so you can make new
parts for it over its life or even use
it to make the house next door so we can
begin to see the seed of a completely
open-source citizen-led
urban development model potentially and
we and others have built a few
prototypes around the world now and some
really interesting lessons here one of
them is that it's always incredibly
sociable people get confused between
construction work and having fun but the
principles of openness go right down
into the really mundane physical details
like never designing a piece that can't
be lifted up or when you're designing a
piece make sure you either can't put it
in the wrong way around or if you do it
doesn't matter because it's symmetrical
probably the principle which runs
deepest with us is the principle set out
by Ninus 12 volts the open source
pioneer which was that idea of be lazy
like a fox don't reinvent the wheel
every time take what already works and
adapt it for your own needs contrary to
almost everything that you might get
taught at an architecture school copying
is good which is appropriate because
actually this approach is not innovative
it's actually how we've built buildings
for hundreds of years before the
Industrial Revolution in these sorts of
community barn raisings the only
difference between traditional
vernacular architecture and open-source
architecture might be a web connection
but it's a really really big difference
we shared the whole of wiki house under
a Creative Commons license and now
what's just beginning to happen is the
groups around the world are beginning to
take it and use it in hack it and tinker
with it and it's amazing there's a cool
group over in Christchurch in New
Zealand looking at post earthquake
development housing and thanks to the
Ted city prize we're working with an
awesome group in one of Rio's favelas to
set up a kind of community factory and
micro University these are very very
small beginnings
and actually there's more people in the
last week who have got in touch and
they're not even on this map I hope next
time you see it you won't even be able
to see the map we're aware that wiki
house is a very small answer but it's a
small answer to a really really big
question which is the globally right now
the fastest-growing cities are not
skyscraper cities they're self-made
cities in one form or another if we're
talking about you know the 21st century
city these are the guys who are going to
be making it you know like it or not
welcome to the world's biggest design
team so if we're serious about problems
like climate change urbanization and
health actually our existing development
models aren't going to do it as I think
Robert new earth said there isn't a bank
or corporation or a government or an NGO
who's going to be able to do it if we
treat citizens only as consumers how
extraordinary would it be though if
collectively we were to develop
solutions not just to the problem of
structure that we've been working on but
to problem infrastructure problems like
solar-powered air conditioning off-grid
energy off-grid sanitation low costs
open source high-performance solutions
that anyone can very very easily make
and put them all into a Commons where
they're owned by everyone and are
accessible by everyone a kind of
Wikipedia for stuff and once something's
in the Commons it will always be there
how much would that change the rules and
I think the technologies on our side
if designs great project in the 20th
century was the democratization of
consumption that was Henry Ford
Levittown coca-cola
IKEA I think designs great project in
the 21st century is the democratization
of production and when it comes to
architecture in cities that really
matters thank you very much
[Applause]
you